what percentage are you Chinese
probably 100 what's up what percent are
you Chinese
what person are you cheating you can ask
that to every Asian well it sounds like
that's the slogan for the commercial
like what's in your wallet
[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
amazing soup chili in this office
episode of the careful boys and today we
have Colleen back in this yeah
she's a morning gal it is a change it's
you look very warm and comfortable I
wish I had more layers that's all I got
to say I knew it was gonna be cold she
tripled up just get used to the cold so
then when it is cold you're just it's
normal yeah acclimate yourselves you
know what ended up happening I loved
like the tropical heat and I was like oh
yeah I can't wait to start living in
Hawaii but then I cold train and then my
body got used to like super cold so now
when I'm there I'm just miserable you
know what Joe I've been taking I've been
taking your advice about cold showers
because [__] every [__] on the
Internet is like yeah dude everyone's
into cold showers I do that [__] dude
that I started doing it and you do feel
a difference I do feel pretty good you
guys listen to it yeah you feel cool no
yeah dude you mean papa papa huberman
then Mr huberman so you do called from
beginning to end your shower nah I'll go
real [__] hot for as long as I can
I'm dreading I'm like yeah dude I want
to do this [__] and then I turn on the
cold and I set a timer and I do it for
like a minute and a half or like two
minutes and I feel like such a little
[__] dude because wait do you do you go
straight to cold or do you like ramp up
no all the way all the way to cold and
then when it hits you you're like
you feel like such a little [__] dude
it's so weird you're not cheating though
because you're going from hot to cold so
your body is already warm so it's not
that bad you should just go from
straight cold okay okay now you're
making me feel like more of a basement
for everybody isn't the change even more
powerful the fact that it was warm and
then it goes see that's what my mindset
was I've done both and personally I
think the worst is when you wake up the
first thing you do when you're half
asleep you want to go back to bed and
you're comfortable and then you hit that
cold shower in your life why oh so you
just jump in on cold yeah I gotta
acclimate that's what I've been doing
and the best part is once you get into
the really cold water and especially
nowadays the water's been getting really
cold like just on the default once you
get cold if you step out of the water
for a second into regular air it feels
so warm it's because that's true it
feels good it feels good okay but can
when you do a Cold Shot doesn't that go
straight to the bones for you yeah come
on hey
[Music]
there's something about it I don't know
you're a good dancer your sweet guy dude
he's really good yeah you got owned in
front he got you you know I I didn't say
great he said good yeah exactly I tried
at my old apartment to do cold showers
but I realized that it was not really
affected because I had those really
really small shower heads so you know
when you do a cold shower and a really
small shower head it's hitting one spot
yeah you're just like I'm really cold
right here and then just kind of like
trinkles out and you don't feel like
you're doing it the right way yeah
that's not nice body part by body part
yeah you gotta blast it you just go top
of that I'm just still a [__] about
that stuff though like it's so it sucks
but if you do feel great would you do
ice yeah I've got an ice bath ice bath
is pretty tight I think I would rather
do an ice bath or something like cry or
something because I feel like you're
really hitting if you're gonna do it you
hit everything you know and you do it
full versus like this like cold showers
kind of like halfway you know what I
mean like I've done things like
cryotherapy and stuff and that stuff
like is banana how does that feel
cryotherapy is getting cold right now
but I do like uh I think ice baths like
suck more because I mean when you're
doing cryo you it it I don't think it's
as cold like it's technically colder but
the water hitting your skin is just
different bro yes yeah yeah what's
what's the what's a better temperature
in the shower for like crying in the
shower
they just think you're laughing yeah
dude you're just sitting in the corner
with your clothes still on yeah
oh that's OTR topic how when's the last
time you guys cried in the shower
no it's not a buy hack but something
really cool that smack did recently is
she bought this like uh it's like a pad
that goes on on the bed oh the chili pad
it's well it's heated oh yeah it's like
an electric chili pad like food it's
super game changing you mean like a like
those warm blankets kind of but it's not
a blanket it's more like a mattress it's
like when you go to a massage parlor and
they have the the heated bench they use
a pad underneath right they're been a
nice place
I treat myself okay where do you get
massages at bro yeah um there's a place
in Sherman Oaks called I'm not going to
tell everybody
they might be waiting for you there
because your fans are going to disguise
themselves come in come in that and also
like
we booked up and then I can't go yeah
because JK news all the JK news fans are
massage lovers that's why they're like
oh I can't find them I can't wait
because she tells a new spot and all of
them are in Sherman Oaks a guy two guys
with a trench coat is gonna be like oh
hi Colleen we're ready for your massage
not sure today
you're not a normal guy her biggest
admirer is getting a massage license so
they can actually see her one day yeah
touch her it starts working there let's
talk about that bro you got fans
you got fans people love Colleen people
love Khalid of course they even talk
about Colleen when she's not here yeah
yeah I remember there was a Kazumi video
and I read a comment where they're like
um please Don't Judge Me Khalid like I
I'm like this is a Kazumi video they
look alike though I get it
yeah uh 21.7 yeah
I haven't been here in a while so you
know too many people are turning in a
23andme's screwing up the skew that's
true that does happen though that does
happen damn you lost your Chinese bars
huh yeah I did I did oh really when I
did the first time I did it I was a 99
Chinese what was the rest and then it
was like 0.4 Japanese days or something
point four percent Japanese I like the
way you say Japanese Japanese so you got
a little bit of colonial
S four to like seven months later now
I'm 50 Taiwanese or some [__]
congratulations
[Laughter]
at this point changes too frequently you
don't even know who you are exactly so
that's why you're only 27 was it 27
Chinese yeah it's 21.7 okay that's cool
that's good that's good 21 I check it
every morning in my cold shower yeah I
can't do nothing that would be so messed
up if they did turn in your results and
it's like you're you're 10 Hong Kong 20
Taiwan AKA pretty much Chinese
like this Emoji
so offensive what percentage are you
Chinese
probably 100 what's up what percent are
you Chinese
you could ask that to every Asian well
it sounds like that's the slogan for the
commercial like what's in your wallet
I'm pretty sure if I took the test it
would be probably like 99.9 Vietnamese
but what if they couldn't see you yeah
yeah but what if they couldn't see me
what are they no they're just doing it
off site
it's like how much Chinese how Chinese
are you find the Chinese guy
damn which one of these guys are Chinese
and you have taika going like this yeah
he's the Judgment I know so the lion
what's weird to me is like how do they
know which based on country I think so
it's like a region but when you do it
23andMe right they'll be like Vietnamese
Chinese or whatever but like
borders don't determine your genetic
like you're just because you're one
border across is my job do you
borderline
borders don't exist my trump
so if you were like Cambodian or
something right like just because you
live like right in that border Zone
and then once you cross it you're now
Vietnamese like I don't know are you
telling us that we wasted our money
is that what you're telling me to do I
think so that's a good point because if
you think about history those lines
change so much over time yeah so how do
they know I don't know but they could
they when were you China yeah when were
you Chinese I feel like the only value
23andMe has is to catch if you like
committed crimes in the past that's it's
pretty much just to get you in the data
yeah they're getting ready for the
future if you'll have crimes committed
against you in the future that's true
that's true okay I didn't they catch you
or they're just selling your data it's
like the AI joke can't don't don't make
it all real dude what the [__] they're
selling our Medical Data they are but
they are they know I have dry earwax now
[__] yeah they do tell you some [__]
up [__] like that yeah like they'll tell
you like oh like you're more likely to
get bitten by mosquitoes like okay thank
you for telling me that like what if
that's the new like identity theft thing
is like the final screening thing is
like how much percentage Chinese are you
instead of like what street did you grow
up on only you know it's gonna be
difficult because it changes so
frequently so the answer is gonna change
so you never know the answer so you'll
never get into the into the system we
have to question
ever yeah you think 50 years from now
everyone's gonna be like Indian or
Chinese
I think I think a little bit like how
much Chinese are you or how much Indian
well according to you know you're you're
you're updated records of interracial
marriages per region oh that's true
you're the database for that it's it's
mostly black and Chinese right now but
you know what's what's strange is as
many Indian people are in the world I
don't see a lot of mixed like I don't
see a lot of Indian something else
because we're not in the UK or Canada oh
does that happen mostly in the UK I
think they not in our teacher they're
more they're more I got a I got a lot of
cousins that have married Indian people
because they're like smart tech people
see Chinese and Indians oh my goodness
if they all get married oh yeah they're
like
play pressure to find another Indian
person the same way that like you know
so yeah other Asians are I've seen a lot
of mixed relationships in the UK because
I think they just been there so so so
long so there's like a lot of do you
guys know when he mixed Indian and like
Asian people do you guys like right now
yeah well I just said like a bunch of my
cousins are marrying like but new
couples right but like older couples
there's a couple of kids what they look
like
whatever that border is between China
and India they look like that
Mike's uh sister is married to a
Nepalese dude and their kids they're
they're super cute but [__] when they
were young I remember I remember being
when they were like young young and
small it was just like they look like
really really cute Asians but have big
eyes so it made it like even more cute
you know what I mean so that was like
one of those things that I was like us
Asians we love big eyes yo yes because
we got yeah double eyelids over here
like yeah she got double eyelids you got
double eyelids too giant eyeballs
looking like Ryan's got big eyes I got
like triple eyelids bro he does he has
them on the bottom and the top he has
quads the options of how to Blink that's
true sometimes like he's got a four by
four Ryan's face looks like it'd be
super fun to make like a memoji oh yeah
oh yeah yes and the hair and beard would
change every [__] week that's why
people think he's Mexican
Mexicans think I'm Mexican yeah for sure
nice for sure that's why Filipinos pass
as Polynesians too but then old Mexicans
think I'm Chinese oh which is cool I
feel like I feel like that's why
Filipinos got so much different like
fashion styles that they could blend
into is because they can also morph what
they are to them he's got a shirt that
said made in Japan right now dude they
could be Japanese they could be oh they
could be everything Japanese dude
there's Filipinos in Japan like right
now that are just imposters
Dad you I thought they were locals and I
go oh hold up you're not even Japanese
one of my buddies he's uh he works with
me his name is Marlin you know Marlin
and every time I have a new client in
the gym and he comes in I always play a
game where I go hey this guy right here
guess what race he is because he's so
he's Filipino Marlon's Filipino he's
Philip exactly exactly he's Filipino 100
but people don't think he's Filipino
yeah 100 100 what do people think he is
oh I don't know he's gotten Persian
Egyptian Armenian Mexican like all kinds
they think he's half black they can't
put their finger on it so he's like
racially ambiguous because Filipinos can
either look like a European guy or a
Chinese man they can be pretty people
say he's like some people say he's
Dominican he's not mixed with Spanish or
anything or you know Filipino yeah
every Filipino we look back far enough
Ken's asking if one of his ancestors
why is a winery even recently Winery I
was talking to my mom and we were
looking at old photos and then my mom my
aunt showed me like my great great
grandfather somebody was like full
Spanish like 100 full beard too huh yeah
straight up how many Phil how many
Filipino dudes do you know with a full
beard like you yeah you got Spaniard
beer dude yeah bro not that many you're
looking like you were on the Santa and
the Pinta Maria
that's like that's the mashup that's the
clap I was on the Kunta mckente
the Mina perinta but I think the the
beard throws it off I think like people
think you're racing ambiguous because
you don't see a lot of Filipino dudes
with the full you should see my like my
Island cousins that are from polilio
which is like a tiny like Island that's
where like my mom's side's from they're
all like they look like black guys like
100 they have like afros wow yeah like
curly naturally I've naturally curly
hair too but it's straightened out as I
grew up my baby pictures I've straight
up afro I was born with an afro and
sideburns you gotta show some of those
[__] pictures I want to see a little
Ryan with the Frog if you had a frozen
sideboard sideburns when you're born
yeah when I was born when I was born
like I had curly hair do your parents
think to themselves like whoa yeah yeah
Dad was like what the [__] is going on
and it's on your mom's side right my mom
said yeah which is weird because my
mom's side is they're uh they're mostly
the women are all light-skinned and then
the guys are hella dark so I don't know
how that happened so interesting are
they working in the fields a little well
they are yeah they're all Boat Boat like
dudes they're working so while they're
working they were [__] some other guy
and then they popped out a baby and that
became the tradition the guy the guy
[Laughter]
in a small island it's really hard to
find some other guy he got that one
light-skinned guy that's just like
chilling in the house Fanning himself
all day and he goes it's it's too hot
today
want to work and they're like well he's
the only dude I remember in the first
time I was in the Philippines in in 89 I
was five years old and I asked my mom if
if like I was like is he black she's
like that's your cousin
I'm just asking why is that bad
she's like no he's just dark
because but you're just curious because
you're just like oh he just likes
hip-hop
that'd be funny if she actually said
that
you're like what's hip-hop and that's
how it started yeah that's how it
started
birth of hip-hop Philippines
this weekend is New Year's Eve Chinese
New Year why are you looking at me
because because you're Chinese celebrate
we're supposed to celebrate Chinese dude
I was gonna go around but I'll celebrate
Chinese New Year yeah with your family
what do you guys what do you guys do
uh basically extended I got a lot of
aunties and uncles and cousins out here
uh in Southern California so we always
go up to like you know somebody's house
in like West Covina the 66 or Temple
City or whatever right and then uh we
just eat a [__] ton of food and then
there's red envelopes based off of your
Asian generation right so it's if there
is something that's uh new now that is
like a very very new thing which is like
because my sister has like three kids
and there's just like new kids that are
coming in like one of my other cousins
has a kid now uh as older cousins we
have to start giving those red envelopes
I'm just gonna ask you that you were
just the the children's generation no
matter how old we got because nobody was
having kids or anything like that so
aunties and uncles would always have to
give it in aged order you know what I
mean oldest youngest are are Lisa right
yes but then now that we got these
little babies coming even though they're
[__] like know her names they're like
don't you still have to do it uh which
means that you know obviously since
we're not used to I'm always showing up
like Mom did you bring any extra
envelopes I get some cash I like I
forgot
does it matter if you're married or not
because that's what my mom told me like
if you're married you give right yeah
you're supposed to give if you're
married I guess who's married uh-oh now
you have the duties of uh yeah it
doesn't matter like if it's older or
younger how much you give them
uh I think um there was definitely a
point where because you know when you're
a kid you [__] you're just checking
all the time right and like the average
for my family again I don't know what an
answer is for anybody else so the
average for my family is always like 20
bucks 20 bucks yeah you know and every
now and then you get like a 10 from like
something you'd be like you [__]
cheap ass and then sometimes uh you know
times are hard 50 bucks or like 100
bucks and it's like maybe that answer
uncle has like a specific relationship
with you or they understand something
about you you know what I mean the only
kid that got the ten dollars in the
group of twenties it's like what the
[__] damn what you guys all get you know
what's cool though is that um when you
go like I I'm not even related to like
my ex's like relatives and but then we
would make our rounds and they would
give me money let's try it as a gesture
yeah but like Japanese people are
[__] cheap bro we don't do that yeah
oh we only do that to our family do you
guys do the lunar is it called Lunar New
Year is that the people so they they do
the same they do the same yes stuff but
then they they swap the date because
when they they when they when they got
industrialized and then they learned
like the Gregorian calendar from the
Europeans and [__] they're like man why
are we gonna celebrate two [__] New
Year's [__] it and then they just did
all the New Year celebrations on January
1st that's what I heard too yeah Colleen
how are you gonna celebrate Chinese New
Year
he doesn't forget his money that's gonna
raise some questions I'm just bringing
it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah dude you
gotta make sure you clean your whole
house make sure you clean your whole
house don't Vietnamese it's like later
right it's the same right how do you
guys or was it Thai uh yeah
no uh we do we make sure we clean the
house we put up the yellow flowers or
the [__] whatever right oh the mice
they're called
it's like a stick
and it has like these little you know
yellow flowers but anyway we clean the
house put the flowers out and then the
day of you're supposed to like invite
somebody of like good energy like good
Role Models someone that's like really
wealthy or whatever to come into your
house
yeah yeah exactly yeah so the first
guest you invite over you got to make
sure you know they're already prosperous
and then another thing is uh you don't
want to sweep on the first day because
you're sweeping out your good luck whoa
that's what you cleaned before damn
there's so many guidelines it's a lot of
rules that's why I ask everybody I'll
just come for the money it happens if
like somebody what happens if somebody
spills something and they're like wait
don't sweet yeah don't clean it leave it
lick it up for good luck
it up for lunch
yeah these are all just superstitious
and like traditions like you guys not
everybody like a special meal because
there's moon cake for oh what's Mooncake
that's a different I think that's a
different holiday
that's like more like a Moon Festival
and this is like we eat uh which is like
the rice cake we Mochi too it's like the
it's not for real though we eat Mochi on
and the rice is like green because of
the banana thing yeah yeah now we're
just talking about [__] that that's
tight oh with like the pork on the
inside something yes yes that's the one
yo I dip that [__] in Sugar like a fat
ass it's supposed to fry it you're
supposed to fry it in the pan fry it and
you dip it in Sugar dude I would love to
eat that that sounds really good I don't
know what it is but anything actually
yeah we should bring some yeah yeah dude
I would love to eat sounds good my mom
would be like hey you want a bunch of
this and I'm like nah but if I have to
share it then I'll be like cool yeah
dude I would love to eat something
actually I'm not gonna be here tomorrow
because yeah I'm not gonna bring it
either yeah
I mean this is a matter but like I'm I'm
gonna be at a festival for actual New
Year
it doesn't matter it's up to you you're
talking to yourself here cut this out
all right keep it in cat make a note to
the editor myself we're also very good
looking yeah do you feel left out
there's no Filipino New Years
I know that's messed up yeah it's [__]
up dude no we don't even we don't care
we don't give a [__] about that
thank you